one of the most poignant parts of your
book matthew was
i learned staring people in the face
there's nothing you can say
the only thing i can can give someone in
that moment is my presence
is this notion that you're not alone you
tell a beautiful story
about suddenly people start recognizing
you
and this idea of hollywood it happened
right it happened
the bomb goes off and it's as beautiful
and it's a blessing as we can imagine
and it's got a dark side to it and you
took off over to a place i've been to
off uh in trauma new mexico
and you met brother christian in this
idea of being known and being heard
basically through silence tell me about
that experience
so i just gotten famous all of a sudden
the world was a mirror
over one weekend was when the time to
kill came out over one weekend
my life changed all of a sudden i wasn't
meeting strangers anymore
everyone had a biography on me oh i'm
sorry matthew about miss hud
and i'm in my mind going number one
how'd you know it's matthew number two
how'd you know i had a dog number three
how you know her name was miss
number four how'd you know she had
cancer whoa that's a lot man
yeah you're just trespassing on my
my life and and so i was getting a lot
of adulation as well i was getting
invited to do almost any script i wanted
where it's just two days before time to
kill came out
i would have done any of those scripts
for nothing and now they're checking
all of them right i'm like i need to
have some discernment right now
to like choose what i want to do and two
days ago i would have done any of these
and now you're telling me i can do all
of them
i got to get out and go hear myself
think see what's going on i mean my feet
are off the ground a little bit
so i went away out there at the uh on
that chime river that monastery
and i and and i just need someone to
talk to
you know shake some monkeys off my back
the world wasn't making sense and
and i met this man brother christian and
we went for a walk about four hour walk
and he listened hands behind back we
walked through that desert for four
hours and i
talk the entire time guilty thoughts
guilty actions what is right what's
making sense it's that the other i'm
confused
we finally come back around to the
chapel four hours later
and i mean my face is soaking wet dried
tears dust in them and everything else
and
i we sit down and i finish off my purge
my
confession basically and he hadn't said
one word in four hours
finally i finish and i'm looking at the
ground and i'm
i'm waiting this to dance yeah wait a
waiting line
yes you are in trouble son and here's
what you got to do
nothing silent silence 15 seconds go by
i finally look up at him
he's just staring at me and he looks me
in the
eye and holds my eyeline for about three
seconds and he says
me too oh i crumbled man i was like
sometimes you don't need to vibe
sometimes you need to be letting though
hey man i just
the human condition man we're all in it
and and he let me know
by saying that that while my
problems were specific to me they
weren't original
[Laughter]
they weren't i didn't have i didn't have
complete ownership of those i didn't
have the ownership of that human
condition everyone feels different
versions of that
so he spread it out and let me know it's
a human
it's a it's it's part of part of living
man part of being a human
well and it's not me to forgive myself
in certain places and gave me the
courage to change certain things
that i need to change that theme of
of we're in it together just weaves its
way through your book and
um i i i'm of the belief that that's the
most
compassionate needed sentiment across
humanity in my own home
here at my office everywhere in my kids
schools is this notion that we're all in
this together
and whether it's your old man saying
don't go halfway
if you're if you're gonna if you're
gonna go go right
and your mom's saying i love you and
you're better than that
and you guys saying don't let them smell
fear and then i'll introduce you
and then that monk and a monastery look
in your head saying hey man me too
and you have now given the
your readership a gift by saying hey i
know every single one of you is stuck
going too fast going too slow wherever
you may be me too
and i want to tell you man i'm grateful
for you appreciate your time